STEWART BRAND: I sort of know you through Brian Eno, an old friend who's been associated
with Long Now for a long time. And your
collaboration with him has been amazing
in terms of the product. But you're
collaborative generally; you seem very
comfortable working with other artists,
and out of the interplay getting
some extra thing. Say more
about how that works for you.
DAVID BYRNE: For me, when a collaboration works—and it
it can work fairly often, pretty
good percentage of times—you get
something extra. You get something that
neither of the collaborators would have
done on their own. And both of them,
or however many there are, realize, "Oh,
this is greater than the sum of its
parts." Or it's a third thing that has
come into existence that is neither of
us, but it's something else.
It doesn't always work. There's
some times when it just doesn't. But when
it does, that's really exciting. I've
heard other musicians say that
they hate the idea of collaborations.
To some, it feels to them that it
is watering down the authenticity of
the author. It's a compromise of some
sort—which it is. You're inevitably
compromising, but if you get something
greater, to me that's worth it.